a policy professor at George Mason
University is blaming the Trump
administration for crimes in Mexico yes
you heard that right
Guadalupe econia Cabrera joins us now to
explain thank you for being here first
of all my question is do you think it's
possible that some of the people who've
been deported back to Mexico or already
committing crimes before they were
deported back to Mexico because you're
saying deportation policies is making
Mexico's life worse explain Mexico and
the United States because people are
very vulnerable and we have cartels at
the border operating at the border and
we have corruption in Mexico therefore
when you deport people to to the border
they find themselves like they want to
come back to the United States they
don't have their families or their
networks and some of them are forced to
participate in the criminal activities
or some of them want to go to the United
States so they hire some smuggler that
are in correction with the with the
cartels I understand that but why is
that our problem well it's not your
problem but you might have a problem as
well because you have more criminal
having criminal groups operating on the
Mexican side of the border and as you
know people are still arriving to the
United States no matter what somebody do
you think we should have any borders
really I mean why have border at this
point I mean why not just make it all
one Mexico in the United States then
then you won't have the cartels would
kind of go out of business because
people will just be all one country I
believe that every country has to have
some kind of limit and I think borders
are important to establish certain
limits to certain forces right but if
you can have a border then presumably
when people don't have permission to be
here then they can be sent home every
country in the face of the planet sends
people home when they don't have
permission and especially if they've
committed a crime and then you're really
subjected to deportation I think
Americans don't feel like it's their
responsibility to make sure that Mexico
we want Mexico to be be well but then
don't allow people to cross the border
real quick I think that you're right but
at the same time the United States can
be threatened by
I mean more violence at the border all
right will you come back so we can do a
really long segment would love love to
have you back